hey what's up guys my name is the chair
welcome back to another one of the two
reaction videos has been a while since
I've done it but today I just I couldn't
resist Microsoft Flight Simulator has
released a new trailer now I've been
following this new Microsoft Flight
Simulator for quite some time last time
a trailer was released I absolutely
loved it it looked absolutely beautiful
and I am a huge flight simulator fan I
haven't really played any flight
simulators probably in the last five to
ten years or so but as a child I I just
I think that like half of my gaming time
like at the time that I've spent gaming
in my entire life I think has been spent
inside flight simulators like il-2
Sturmovik Microsoft Flight Simulator X a
little bit morality or stellar anyway
point is I love planes I actually
trained to be a pilot and I've flown
quite a few hours solar as well so I am
very much into planes I'm very much into
flying I can't wait to take a look at
this haven't looked at this trailer yet
I know it's gonna look beautiful because
why wouldn't it I'm just really excited
let's jump in and take a look okay so
captured in real time 4k and this is on
an Xbox cool I didn't even know that so
this is great we've been looking at so
much PlayStation 5 stuff people have
been getting on me to look at some Xbox
stuff and finally there's something to
look at
gotta start with the gold now shot it's
so nice
[Music]
plus a star would like some pipe a plane
no one's gonna fly
so much detail there in the ocean
oh wow look at those clouds man those
clouds look like a painting I'm not even
sure if they necessarily look real but I
don't think I even care they look like a
painting that looks beautiful look at
the wing wobble that's realistic okay
hold on hold on by the way I say this
every time but the link to this is in
the description if you have not seen it
watch it now first without me you don't
need me to watch this trailer because
I'm gonna pause it and I'm probably
gonna annoy a lot of people as usual
okay
that is beautiful this is boring this is
beautiful that's why a lot of these
cases in a lot of cases game companies
and in fact anyone working on 3d art on
any art really likes to try and create
the most dramatic looking golden hour
shot this translates to everything this
translates to like photography
everyone's trying to take photos during
golden hour why because it just simply
makes everything look better this
doesn't really have anything to do with
like the quality of the trailer or the
game or anything like that but I just
wanted to point that out that it's nice
to see some really nice shots like this
in the game and it definitely helps to
sell like a let me look at this
look at all of that detail and look at
that water reflection I'm really
interested to see whether like how
dynamic this whole weather like daylight
system is because I imagine it's pretty
much fully dynamic I mean it's a flight
simulator right so if you're making a
long 12-hour flight you probably will
see like the weather and the actual like
time of day change not to mention if
you're flying across time zones and
stuff like that so I mean it's got to be
like fully dynamic in which case like
this this is really this is some really
nice stuff and also I'm not sure if that
I mean I imagine that some cities are
gonna be really really like detailed and
well-made and then other cities are
probably gonna be a little bit more
sparse unless they're actually pulling
data from like Google Earth or Google
Maps or something like this which they
they might be doing in which case that
probably be a good way to go I think
because some of the biggest problems
with the previous flight simulator games
weather some areas were just really not
dance I mean it's made by an American
company a lot of the cities in the US
are great but I remember I live in
Australia
I remember playing around like Melbourne
Airport and like those kind of my local
areas basically and it was like it was
pretty sparse or I heard that that's
been improved oh my gosh look at that
folk look at that rainbow look at that
city look at that that's so much detail
I mean it looks like some flat stuff
over there but maybe that just hasn't
like popped in yet but like that's a lot
of stuff going on I'm I'm I'm very
impressed already I mean I don't
remember what the last trailer I watched
was but I remember being quite impressed
by that as well
look at those environments man it looks
like a photo look at that this might be
worth getting like a VR headset for
actually
there's that fog Wow look at that dense
fog I have like no critique so far like
I'm being completely honest that looks
plain but that's just good as daylight
look at look at that mountain
look at that forest you guys thought
PlayStation was paying me turns out the
whole time Xbox was paying me no I'm
just kidding but this looks absolutely
phenomenal that reflection is super nice
and that looks like there's quite a bit
of wobble in it which is even better and
I mean look at that reflection this is
this is this is really really cool
pretty standard comp it looks a bit and
taught to tell could just be flat
lighting because of the lighting but the
building looks great does a bug on my
screen
[Music]
oh my gosh look at that heat blur look
at that heat blur look at that look at
that detail aha
they haven't shown so far they haven't
really shown any shots of like flying
and really low and trying to like you
know just fly around in between
buildings and stuff I don't know what
the details gonna translate to
especially outside of the main city if
you look at the actual outskirts of the
town for example flying through the
buildings how how how detailed are they
going to be no way really to tell but of
course most of your time is gonna be up
in the air like this and this looks
phenomenal so look at that is that a
reflection that is a reflection look at
that reflection of that fin and look at
the live reflection of the landing gear
opening
look at all those lights look at look
look at that reflection this makes me so
happy I don't even know why I was not I
was not in the best mood prior to
watching this but right now look at that
like look at that opening you can see
the reflection of the environment of the
clouds which is what I would expect but
there's also this is like clearly a ray
traced reflection of like this kind of
whole plane or like the wing itself
actually I don't even know yet I guess
that would be reflecting like this part
of the wing or something like that
doesn't look like there's multiple
bounces because you'd probably see a
little bit of the pink sky inside this
actual reflection from bouncing onto
this wing and then bouncing onto the
cloud but you know we'll forgive them
their multiple bounces may not be a
thing yet now I'm watching this at 4k
and stuff but like it's hard to tell the
resolution of this shadow but I mean it
looks perfect to me so I don't tell me
there are like AI people walking around
as well look the people models the
people could use some work that
animation was a little bit stiff the arm
is just kind of by his side but you know
what it's a flight simulator the fact
that there are even people in there
that's cool in an in and of itself look
at the light reflecting everything look
at the depth of field
[Music]
well there's alliance I mean that could
just be dots instant like I just the
thing that makes this even more
impressive to me is that I've played
flight simulators before so I know just
how big they are they are like the
ultimate open-world game like yes you
can't go into every building like in an
in an RPG or something like that and not
everything is like interactive but in
terms of like the sheer size of it I
mean you can fly around the world right
everything has to be there and again I'm
sure they're showing the most detailed
cities that they've specifically worked
on but just looking at this like it I
just I know how much work needs to go
into this and I know how how big of a
deal this kind of open-world environment
actually is so it's just it blows my
mind
August 18 well I know what I'm doing on
August 18 I'm gonna be playing this game
I don't I don't really know how like
probably on a computer my each upgrade I
need money to upgrade my computer for
this but I don't know what this has to
do it like the Xbox isn't gonna be out
then is it so I don't know what I don't
know like I guess you can you'll be able
to play it on PC until then oh man what
I mean you guys saw my reaction that was
a hundred percent real my first time
watching this that was my genuine
reaction I'm you know I mean I I did
start off with that disclaimer that I am
really into flight simulators even
though I haven't played them for years I
can't wait to play this I will I think
I'll definitely check this out and I
don't know what else to say let me know
what you thought of this video in the
comment section below
are you as blown away as I am is this
kind of like is this boring too I mean I
don't know how many people are into
flight simulators because it's probably
not the most like entertaining game to
play but as someone who's really into
flying and all of that stuff and who is
loved like planes and aircraft and stuff
since being like 6 years old
I I just absolutely love this stuff if
there's something else that you want me
to react to because it's been a while
since my last reaction and maybe I'll
make some more of these videos in the
future drop a comment below as well and
I will
be happy to take a look at that if you
see a comment that already mentions that
just thumbs it up and whatever wins in
terms of up votes I will probably take a
look at that next but yeah I don't know
how much of this is like this is running
on an Xbox as well probably worth
mentioning very impressive
right not sure what like if the PS 5
would be capable of this I don't really
care and I don't really want to get into
console wars looks phenomenal on the
Xbox more power to the Xbox like for
being able to run this stuff that's
great and not more power than the PS 5
exactly the same amount of power to xbox
as PS 5 that's how I feel right now this
was absolutely brilliant I can't wait to
play this on my computer and I will see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you